[Música]
[Aplausos]
bom gente vocês estão de olhos vendados
nesse momento a gente tentar fazer uma
experiência sem enxergar né pra vocês
simplesmente escutarem a minha voz e por
uma questão de igualdade também porque
eu também não enxergo nem toda a
palestra obviamente vai agradar todo
mundo então vocês podem ficar à vontade
para dormir mas por favor não com que
cego escuta muito bem e é um pouco
constrangedor eu diria né
quando eu ou foi convidado para
participar do ted eu fiquei pensando em
algo que tivesse relação com a
comunidade e que eu pudesse compartilhar
pra vocês que fosse algo muito caro pra
mim então eu pensei na responsabilidade
eu nem sempre fui cego na verdade eu me
tornei cego aos 33 anos por uma
negligência pessoal minha
o médico falou que ia ficar cego e sabe
aquela história que a gente chega no
médico e ele falou assim exagerando e
não era um risco e uma certa forma foi
obrigado a assumir a responsabilidade
pela minha atitude a talvez esse tenha
sido o episódio na minha vida é aonde a
responsabilidade e se apresentou de
forma mais contundente mais impactante
na minha vida eu gostaria de convidar
vocês pra gente fazer um passeio pela
psicologia e verão em algumas teorias
psicológicas para a gente entender o que
essa responsabilidade
eu era uma pessoa antes de a série c já
viram que o desenho do pateta que ele
senta atrás de um volante e de repente
ele vira um monstro e começa a xingar
todo mundo e tal e aquela confusão toda
eu era mais ou menos esse tipo de pessoa
a pessoa extremamente ranzinza uma
pessoa
posso dizer que fui infeliz né com a
minha vida da forma como ela era e por
incrível que pareça a deficiência visual
ela me trouxe muitos ganhos
inclusive eu me casei
escutando e eficiente pessoal esposa
porém em algum lugar mas eu não consigo
ver então à espera que ela esteja bom
responsabilidade
vamos dividir a palavra responsabilidade
é é inglês response ability néel do
inglês seria responsabilidade é é a
habilidade em responder mas a habilidade
de responder o que responder aos
estímulos do mundo
quando a gente nasce a gente tem sempre
um outro como referencial seja nosso pai
mãe bá bá cuidador seja quem for tem
alguém que vai introduzir a gente no
mundo que vai dizer pra gente da
linguagem da cultura das normas sociais
e ao longo da nossa vida
à medida que ele vai crescendo outras
pessoas vão nos influenciam no amigos
professores colegas ea gente vai
absorvendo um pouco dessa personalidade
que ética da união apenas aquilo que os
nossos pais ou cuidadores ensinaram
mas a gente vai absorvendo um pouco de
cada um
então a nossa personalidade na verdade é
uma miríade é uma quantidade incontável
de pequenos pedaços de personalidades de
várias outras pessoas que a gente
condensa na gente e que a gente vai
absorvendo jogando aquilo que é ou não
adequado pra nós né e no que isso
impacta na responsabilidade na
deficiência visual ou mesmo na
comunidade muito porque a partir desses
referenciais que a gente vai começar a
interpretar tudo o que a gente vive no
mundo
a apsi ecologia comportamental ela fala
pra gente de dois conceitos básicos que
o reforço ea punição reforço é quando a
gente faz alguma coisa e como
conseqüência a gente recebe por exemplo
um prêmio um elogio à nossa tendência
obviamente vai ser de repetir o
comportamento não de contas quem gosta
de ir sempre longe um prêmio
no caso da punição é o contrário ou seja
eu posso encarcerada posso levar uma
multa após levar um fora enfim de alguma
forma eu você punido por alguma algum
comportamento
no caso da a psicologia do
desenvolvimento
alguns teóricos falam em assimilação e
acomodação
imagine um bebê com uma bola né o bebê
rola bola a lb o legal a bola rolou
depois ele pega a bola quicar a bola a
bola quicou ele pega a bola e joga na
cabeça do rock rock cabeça dos outros e
aí ele vai experimentando então através
das simulações e acomodações dessas
experiências em contato com o mundo
o bb vai criando esquemas ea gente vai
complexificando e sistemas ao longo da
nossa vida na psicanálise a gente já tem
um outro conceito que é a as nossas
defesas psíquicas que a gente cria para
podermos garantir contra as angústias
que a gente sente durante a vida porque
eu tô dizendo tudo isso pra vocês porque
no final das contas a nossa
interpretação do mundo ela sempre vai
passar por todo é toda essa experiência
que a gente teve com reforço a punição
com os esquemas que a gente montou com
os nossos mecanismos de defesa
não importa como mas a gente vai
interpretar o mundo e muitas vezes a
gente carrega engodo né a gente cai na
enganação de fazer um julgamento
precipitado como por exemplo no caso dos
estereótipos que são estereótipos
estereótipos é uma rotulação social que
você faz
a partir de um conceito preestabelecido
de um grupo social geralmente fazendo
algum tipo de julgamento seja ele
positivo ou negativo
então as nossas experiências vão
conduzindo a gente a dizer o que é bom
que não é o que é temerário o que não é
e não quer que isso impacta pra gente na
comunidade muito porque às vezes a gente
vai olhar para um outro do nosso lado
seja ele deficiente seja homossexual
seja mulher seja negro seja que tipo de
grupo social folk ser que tenha algum
tipo de discriminação ea gente pode ter
medo porque nós aprendemos muitas vezes
até medo dessas pessoas
bom e como é que a gente se lembra disso
a psicanálise ela fala pra gente de uma
coisa chamada desejo pra gente trabalhou
muito com isso é um primeiro passo a
gente tem um desejo o desejo de mudar
o segundo passo para falar dele eu vou
remeter a uma frase que uma professora
minha falou quando ela estava dando pra
mim psicologia existencial liberdade é
fazer escolhas responsáveis e aqui eu
vou tentar conectar tudo que a gente
tudo que ouvi falando para vocês até
agora
liberdade não é a gente fazer tudo que a
gente quer a liberdade é você saber
escolher entre as possibilidades que
você tem e assumir a responsabilidade os
riscos por essa escolha ea única coisa
da qual nós não podemos nos esquivar
durante toda a nossa vida que escolhi
porque quando nós nos recusamos fazer
uma escolha
a gente está escolhendo não escolher
então é a única coisa que a gente
realmente não consegue se esquivar
independente de qual seja a situação
caótica em que se encontra é pra
exemplificar um pouco eu acho que eu vou
citar alguns exemplos aqui que eu acho
que vai ficar um pouco mais claro que eu
queria dizer pra vocês
minha mãe detestava cegos mas é verdade
parece uma piada do destino que eu tenha
me tornado cego depois de adulto mas
minha mãe de testar os cegos que
aconteceu
ela foi ajudar um cego atravessar uma
rua uma avenida e quando você vai ajudar
a atravessar um cego você oferece o
braço pra ele ele segura normalmente no
seu cotovelo ou o no ombro né dependendo
da estatura pessoa e e aí você vai um
passo à frente do deficiente visual ele
vai te acompanhando ali
no entanto o esse rapaz quando pegou no
braço da minha mãe começou a vazar no
seio dela ela tem vontade de enfiar a
mão na cara dele
obviamente como eu imagino que a maioria
das mulheres teria vontade de fazer mas
ela não fez isso porque estou dizendo
isso para vocês porque a minha mãe teve
um desejo que foi de ajudar uma pessoa
com deficiência ela fez uma escolha e
ela assumiu a responsabilidade por essa
escolha
o deficiente por sua vez ele também
tinha um desejo embora não fosse apenas
atravessar ou infelizmente ele tinha uma
escolha ele tinha uma responsabilidade e
olha como isso é impactante
vou contar um outro exemplo para vocês
mas vocês entenderem o que eu quero
dizer
eu estava parado na calçada um dia
tentar atravessar uma avenida e viu duas
moças passando por trás de mim
conversando animadamente obviamente bay
para trás pedir a elas nem por favor
posso me ajuda a atravessar ou ela se
calaram passaram por trás de mim
bom eu não sou surdo obviamente eu
escutei os passos dela passa por trás de
mim e minha mãe me deu uma boa educação
é grande e 50 obrigado a ficar
aguardando outra pessoa pra poder me
ajudar a atravessar a rua porque eu tô
contando isso a vocês porque às vezes a
gente pode pensar né que vamos supor que
essas moças elas tivessem passado pela
mesma experiência que a minha mãe passou
elas não teriam nenhuma vontade divina
uma pessoa uma pessoa deficiente visual
porque nós temos a tendência de
generalizar as experiências que a gente
tem principalmente quando a gente entra
em contato com alguma situação com
alguma experiência para a qual a gente
não tem algum tipo de esquema já
pré-estabelecido então quando a gente
desconhece alguma coisa a gente teme que
quando a gente tenha a gente evita citar
um outro exemplo para vocês que eu não
sei se é experiência ou inexperiência da
pessoa
mais uma vez eu estava novamente
tentando atravessar uma avenida em
frente passos o pátio savassi helena
contorno e tinha um casal jovem passando
por mim eu pedi ajuda a moça se
prontificou a mesma hora a não pois não
tá nem ofereceu braço e atravessou
chegou até o campo
o central então tá tchau viram as costas
eu fiquei pensando que diabos eu vou
fazer no canteiro central
aí o rapaz que estava com ela virou-se
não pára aí vamos ajudar em tal ela deu
aquela suspirar assim
aí fico pensando assim né ela deve ter
pensado assim que segue abusado nem eu
já joguei atravessar até a metade da
menina para quem quer chegar do outro
lado
aí ela veio e me ajudou a atravessar até
o outro lado da menina ea essa altura já
estava na minha gargalhada é eu duvido
muito que essa pessoa tenha tido tem
aprendido alguma coisa com essa
experiência porque na verdade quando a
gente vai fazer alguma coisa a gente tem
que fazer espontaneamente tem que fazer
decoração e quando a gente faz por
coação que foi o caso dela ou seja o
amigo dela namorado sei lá quem for
chamou a atenção dela por um fato que
ela não tinha prestado atenção naquele
momento eu tenho minhas dúvidas se ela
realmente aprender alguma coisa com isso
então eu acho que essa atenção a gente
precisa ter
caso a gente queira fazer diferença na
nossa comunidade que está cheio de
possibilidades à nossa volta
eu acho que a gente tem que ter essa
devida atenção essa espontaneidade
se vocês quiserem vocês podem tirar não
não tinha vindo de você por agora não eu
quero falar uma coisa para vocês vocês
têm a opção de tirar a venda
eu não tenho mas podem tirar vendo agora
podem tirar porque afinal de contas não
é vocês enxergam né
espero que não seja muito feio acho que
não sou tão assustador assim mas enfim
vocês devem ter recebido junto com com
essa venda um cordão zinco 12 nós
se não tiver dois nós por favor façam
dois nós distantes um do outro quando
vocês saírem daqui hoje eu quero que
vocês
façam a qualquer momento na sua casa um
momento que vocês tiverem tempo vendem
os seus olhos o fecho os olhos e tenta
desatar um dos nós de olhos fechados
marquinhos tempo e depois vocês abram os
olhos e tenta desatar o segundo nó irmã
que o tempo com isso vocês vão perceber
a dificuldade de uma pessoa com
deficiência visual mesmo que seja uma
experiência mínima
se vocês quiserem saber a dificuldade
por exemplo de um cadeirante senta numa
cadeira de rodas vai tentar andar na rua
se vocês quiserem saber por exemplo a
dificuldade de uma pessoa com
deficiência auditiva
aprendo um pouco de libras e tenta se
comunicar com alguém na praça sete sem
falar uma palavra
vocês vão entender exatamente do que eu
estou falando com vocês
então nós temos a a psicologia
comportamental
a psicologia do desenvolvimento e
psicanálise todas essas falam pra gente
de um certo determinismo um certo de uma
certa forma do nosso comportamento
acontecer a partir de experiências que
nós tivemos previamente mas nós temos a
opção nós temos desejos nós temos
escolhas e nós temos responsabilidade
então eu quero a mensagem que quero
deixar para vocês é o seguinte não
importa o que o mundo fez com vocês o
que importa é o que vocês vão fazer com
que o mundo fia de vocês vocês vão sair
daqui hoje e vocês não vão conseguir
mudar o mundo mas se vocês mudarem vocês
de alguma forma a forma como vocês vão
enxergar o mundo vai ser diferente o
mundo vai mudar pra vocês
fernando pessoa em um dos seus poemas
ele disse a seguinte frase o que não é
tudo
se não o que pensamos de tudo muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]
ae